all right big news head of the sports
world tonight the PGA Tour announced a
merger with the Rival live golf tour
which is funded by the Saudi Sovereign
wealth fund now Liv Goff has been
lowering some of the world's best
golfers away from the PGA with extremely
lucrative contracts news of that merger
came to a surprise to many but not
former president Donald Trump he
actually predicted that this would
happen about 11 months ago and for his
part President Biden had no comment on
the deal other than a joke about joining
the PGA Tour himself now I would tell
Joe you might want to keep your day job
because you like to sleep a lot I don't
really want that either but anyway amid
Biden's mental and physical struggles
there are now growing calls for him to
step aside our friend Stephen A Smith
host of the Stephen A Smith Show podcast
of which I have been a guest is here for
is the latest to call for change at the
White House he joins us right now sir
how are you
nice to see you you got a nice haircut
too thank you go ahead I appreciate you
you're noticing
um I will say this when I read somebody
else a new hire at ESPN is being paid
more than you no that no you are the
star at ESPN you get paid more period
I'm not concerned
what's that I've I've been treated very
well and when my time has could come
again I'll be treated very well again I
am not concerned don't worry about me
everything just know where I stand I
want you to know I'm on your side I
think you should be the highest paid
just saying uh all right I was at the
time and I will be again
you will that's that's true I have no
doubt I know you will all right so
Biden's too old too checked out get it
but my staff tells me you're friends
with Chris Christie you know you don't
want him for president do you
I'd rather have them for president than
Donald Trump I'll be the first to admit
that I understand and he's got a
gladiatorial attitude and he's ready for
to come back to combat we know what he
did to Marco Rubio in 2016 during the
primaries and all of that stuff we get
all of that I think that he's a guy that
is not walking around and preaching
about you know a rigged elections and
all of this other stuff he's about
moving the country forward I don't know
whether he'll win or not I know it's a
long shot I understand that Donald
Trump's got him beat by a model at this
particular moment in time but in the
same breath I don't think he's going to
be pushed around by the former president
and I think that Chris Christie knows
what he's talking about he's highly
intelligent he's highly accomplishment
I don't know but we'll see why did he
why did he leave office for the 14
approval rating we all remember Bridge
gate although that ended up being not so
much squishy on over ruled in a an
appeal but then there he is you know
sitting on a beach that he closed
himself one rule for him one rule for
the rest of the people in New Jersey
well wait a minute in it well first of
all that's something that I'm supposed
to be bringing up I'm surprised you're
bringing that up about a conservative
and a republican candidate way to go for
you Sean but at the end he's trying to
can't pay for Chris Christie or anything
no I I I I I listen the bottom line is
he's certainly not a liberal uh the
bottom line is this when you look at him
and I think that you know he's competent
and more importantly he's going to be
talking about issues as opposed to
having us distracted with a whole bunch
of nonsense that we don't need to be
distracted with as a country that's all
I'm saying now whether he wins and I
know it's a long shot I know it's a very
long shot but I tell you this much I'd
vote for him before I'd vote for any of
the democratic candidates that I've seen
but that's not the same when it comes to
DeSantis or Trump but when it comes to
him I know that's what position I take
I'm a registered independent you
understand and that's what I would say
that's how I feel about it now why is it
you see it I see it the world sees it
that is Joe Biden is you know weak frail
and cognitively he's out to lunch why
can't Democrats just admit that simple
truth
well because he's the candidate number
one that they deem uh capable of beating
Donald Trump which he's already proven
whether people want to admit that or not
that's number one number two and more
importantly I'm not going to sit up
there and label our president and those
derogatory Fashions what I will say is
this I'm not engaging in agencies
I didn't say you were
do you think he's a cognitive message
I'm not going to say he's a cognitive
I'm not going there what I can say to
you is that I think there's an abundance
of people who could do better and I hate
the fact that
we have a bunch of liberal candidates
out there that thinking and I'm like
what the hell is wrong for being
straightforward blunt truthful and
honest and you can't say you can't say
the you can't speak the obvious that Joe
Biden's a cognitive mess
of course he's a cognitive master I'm
not going to labor excuse me I'm not
going to label it that way Sean what I'm
going to tell you is this I'm looking at
him and I don't like what I see I'm not
impressed with what I've seen I've been
very concerned with what I've seen and
the fact that he's going to be 82 years
of age at election time if he would have
won an election and he'd be in the white
house until he's 86 years old I think in
the year 2023 it is utterly embarrassing
that the liberal side has him as their
best candidate what does it say about
you when that is the best candidate that
you can give the left that is ridiculous
that's not a knock against Joe Biden
it's an indictment against the
Democratic party it took a little push
now I got Stephen A coming out of his
shell I was waiting for that all right
now let me move on to live golf I'm
going to tell you something and I'm I
don't like to speak you know in
generalities but broadly speak taking as
a country I have found the Saudis to be
dishonest and duplicitous and I I find
them to be a fair weather friend of
America and when it's in their best
interest to align with China as they're
currently doing they do it I don't I
don't like this at all uh I think the
PGA gave in because they thought they
were going to lose and there was too
much money on the table thoughts
well that's exactly what happened the
fact of the matter as far as I'm
concerned they came to their senses and
even though uh Jay Mona and the PGA
commissioner said one thing months ago
and completely reversed course now
um I'm certainly going to applaud it for
it as I did this morning on first take
on ESPN here's the reality of the
situation the United States government
does business with Saudi Arabia for
billions of dollars it was a nine
billion dollar Surplus for the
government in 2019. they did over 138
billion dollars in sales and goods when
with Saudi Arabia in the year 2019. the
reality is is that if the government of
the United States can do business with
Saudi Arabia what on Earth is wrong with
individual golfers doing business with
Saudi Arabia we've got to be consistent
as a nation which is one of the things
that I completely are I repeatedly argue
with you about all the time about
consistency in terms of our society if
you have a problem with golfers then
have a problem with our government if
you Don don't have a problem with our
government doing business what on Earth
are you bothering golfers for whether
it's Phil Mickelson
Dr Johnson whomever
being treated right by the PGA they want
an alternative what happened in World
War II didn't the the U.S align for a
time with the former Soviet Union to
beat Nazi Germany uh that was an
alliance of convenience we still didn't
like each other I mean a patented his
way he'd go it would have gone right
straight into uh uh the Soviet Union at
that time but we only got a second I
gotta roll can I report can I return to
that real quick let me throw this at you
what happened to the American way in
capitalism the fact of the matter is the
PGA was a monopoly live golf comes along
because the PGA presumably wasn't
treating the golfers right they made
that case live golf comes along they
throw through two billion and all of a
sudden
and they collaborate with live golf
exactly in our country we have more
energy resources than they do and we're
stupid enough we don't produce a
domestic and we're making them rich and
we're now making Venezuela Rich Stephen
A Smith should be the highest paid ESPN
commentator by far
thank you Stephen A hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else